girls we also don't know what we want  they actually they actually say that  women prefer fat guys with muscles over  skinny guys like because I think it  boils down to protection if the dude's  that big like you think you think he can  protect you I know Fighters will say  it's not all about that I mean look I  don't I'm just saying what it looks like  as a girl I don't meet a lot of women  who who say like I need a guy with  really really low body fat percentage  but at the same time all the guys I know  who have like chiseled lines and ripped  abs and stuff are drowning and because  if they tend shirt off and take a photo  and put it on Instagram their DMS Are  Gonna Fill Up with chicks because that  just grabs attention you know